sony and ubisoft reveal some games for
the playstation plus refresh and more
let's be honest monday mornings are lame
but learning what games are coming to
the new playstation plus on a monday
morning now that's pretty awesome today
sony confirmed a list of games that will
be available as part of its overhauled
ps plus subscription service which
includes a selection of playstation 4
and playstation 5 titles for the ps plus
extra and premium tiers several games
from playstation studios like marvel
spider-man return all and demon souls
will be made available in the new game
catalog alongside third-party titles
such as assassin's creed valhalla
control ultimate edition and mortal
kombat 11. this is perfect for someone
like me who has been itching to try out
fraternal and demon souls but has
hesitated because of their difficulty
classic games from the original
playstation and psp will also be made
available through a smaller library
which also includes a mix of first and
third party games sony says that classic
games will come with a new interface
menus and quality of life features that
allow a user to rewind gameplay and save
their progress from any point and for
players who have previously purchased
the digital versions of these classic
games you won't have to buy them again
or sign up for playstation plus to
access them on the ps4 or ps5 sony also
included a partial list of the ps3 games
that will be available through streaming
and upcoming game trials ps plus
essential which is essentially the same
as the current ps plus will still
continue to offer two free games as part
of their subscription every month but
the playstation plus extra and premium
users will be able to access additional
games in the middle of the month
according to sony the number of games
refreshed will vary per month you can
check out the entire list of games over
on gamespot.com and i'll leave a link in
the description but whoa hang on don't
click that link just yet because the
sony news doesn't stop there as a part
of the refresh ps plus ubisoft plus
classics is being bundled into the
playstation plus extra and premium tiers
ubisoft plus classics will launch with
27 curated games on june 30th in the us
and the lineup is expected to grow to
around 50 games by the end of the year
the initial list includes ac valhalla
for honor and a few trials games the
standard version of ubisoft plus will be
added to playstation at a later date the
service will also be coming to xbox in
the future and more of its games will be
available through game pass as a part of
a new deal between the companies so now
that you have this large preview of what
the new ps plus will look like are you
sold let me know in the comments and
while sony was dropping a list of games
warner brothers was busy revealing new
characters for its upcoming free-to-play
platform fighter multiverses a new
cinematic trailer shows a few characters
we've already seen being forced to team
up including batman and shaggy bugs
bunny and arya stark garnett from steven
universe and jake from adventure time
harley quinn also makes an appearance
but her teammate is the trailer's first
confirmed new character the tasmanian
devil from looney tunes the end of the
trailer also teases two more new
additions to the roster velma from
scooby-doo and the iron giant from the
1999 film before confirming an open beta
test is coming in july more details on
the closed alpha test scheduled for may
19th through the 27th were also unveiled
as the test will feature 15 characters
including taz and velma as well as seven
maps ranging from the bat cave to the
haunted mansion from scooby-doo the test
will feature multiple game modes
including 2v2 1v1 4 player free for all
and a training mode hit the comment
section and let me know who you're
planning to main in multiverses and i'll
see you tomorrow
you